we have big breaking news tonight Wall
Street Journal just out with a major
report here's the headline Trump lawyers
seek deal with mauler to speed end of
Russia probe now White House sources
they're pushing back on some aspects of
the story but here is what we are being
told at this hour negotiations are
underway on how the president will be
questioned by the special counsel robert
muller
and they are close to now determining
what is going to happen my
interpretation of all this it means this
witch-hunt could finally be wrapping up
because the president would be the last
person that Muller would want to talk to
and by the way to me that means that a
conclusion is probably coming soon and
that would mean yeah Donald Trump did
not collude with the Russians a big
development we're following closely
tonight and also breaking more breaking
news on a bombshell development that we
broke on this program last night Sarah
Carter will join us she has new
information about the Iranian one
informant that is said to have proof of
a Clinton Foundation quid pro quo
now Victoria ton Singh who also join us
the lawyer for the informant is
revealing that her client William
Campbell was interviewed in December of
last year by the FBI in Arkansas as part
of an ongoing investigation into the
Clinton Foundation ongoing now because
the information of this informant has
Democrats preemptively in the media they
are now trying to discredit this
informant who spend decades of his life
serving his country you have
congressional Democrats releasing a memo
yesterday to the hill trashing this
informant William Campbell's credibility
now these smears were then picked up on
and published by liberal outlets like
the Washington Post predictably CNN fake
news Reuters in Yahoo now here's the one
thing that none of those organizations
ever reached out to Victoria ton Singh
for a comment now we're going to give
her a chance to defend her client
completely against an untrue smear what
this is is a partisan left-wing attack
just designed to protect Hillary Clinton
her foundation and what they did it
never made sense to give 20% of our
uranium to Russia and the left in this
country they know this FBI informant he
was in Putin's Network
he has damaging information on the
Clintons that potentially could send
them to jail so they're lashing out
Victoria tun Singh Sara Carter will have
the details that's coming up tonight now
we also have new information on another
major breaking news story special
counsel Jeff sessions he's continuing to
suggest that he is strongly now
considering doing what we have been
saying for a long time needed to be done
that would be appointing a second second
special counsel to investigate rampant
FISA abuses and abuse within the FBI and
the DOJ here's what we know the FBI lied
to the FISA Court by using an unverified
dossier bought and paid for by Hillary
Clinton to get a warrant to spy on an
associate of the Trump campaign during
an election the FBI broke the FISA law
and they also did not follow the
bureau's own protocols by relying
heavily on what was something that they
themselves should have verified and
corroborated you know remember a former
deputy FBI director Andrew McCain he's
testified without the dossier they
wouldn't have even had a FISA
application a huge development major
scandal I know the media ignores it
they'll have egg on their face and
another breaking story tonight President
Trump finally his issued a pardon for
Christiane saucier this is an issue we
talked about for a long time you might
remember our extensive extensive
coverage of this case now saucier is a
former US Navy sailor he was convicted
of a felony and in prison for a year
from quote mishandling classified
information he took a few photos where
he worked inside a submarine 40 year old
submarine that were discovered on
Sasuke's discarded cell phone he didn't
give it to anybody now this became a
huge issue on the 2016 campaign trail
highlighting a major disparity in a
criminal justice system remember Hillary
Clinton mishandled an enormous amount of
top-secret special access classified
information on that unauthorized private
server and then she deleted 3d 33,000
subpoenaed emails and she received no
punishment for those James Comey
Pieterse trucking company well the fix
was in and they rigged the outcome now
meanwhile saucier did
fraction of what Clinton did he was sent
to prison for a year and thankfully
President Trump today and rightly today
he corrected this injustice and
Christian saucier can now move on with
his life
you know even more breaking information
to tell you about Fox News reporting the
house Intel committee they are sending
ten key questions about the dossier to
two more obama administration officials
one of them who worked as a key advisor
for barack obama and joe biden is
actually married to a senior fusion gps
employee now this is drawing comparisons
to demoted DOJ official Bruce oar and
his wife Nellie who worked on that fake
news dossier perfusion GPS now the other
officials served as a former national
security adviser to Biden so this
scandal is getting bigger and bigger by
the day now the house Intel Committee
Chairman Devin Nunez revealed earlier
this week that he has received some
responses about the dossier from some
top Obama officials others so far
refusing to comply
so Nunez is now threatening to issue
subpoenas which he should do and finally
president Trump's major win with North
Korea is sending the media into a
hate-filled frenzy the partisan press is
absolutely going apoplectic over the
fact that president Trump's peace
through strength approach with dealing
with little Rocketman Kim jong-un is now
yielding positive results we may have
peace in the Korean Peninsula now this
breaking news that the president is
agreeing to meet with the North Korean
dictator to discuss denuclearization is
now apparently aggravating and incensing
liberal lapdog media people as they're
physically and mentally incapable of
reporting any positive news about this
president watch this is a role of a
nuclear dice in some ways the president
kind of got boxed in here he couldn't
say no to this invitation I think the
entire foreign policy community and a
good deal of the informed public freaked
out last night when they thought Trump
was actually gonna get in a room with
this guy with no conditions and start
talking we've just given Kim Jeong
something for nothing I'm very concerned
about what this administration would be
willing to barter away why
the other president ever done should I
take that to mean that this might be a
particularly risky or even an unwise
move but this is the president we have
and he said yes to North Korea it but
he's not sending a hundred and fifty
billion dollars in cash and other
currencies and he's not giving billions
of dollars to the North Koreans
he gave nothing but the destroyed Trump
media they love the policies of
appeasement of Barack Obama and
President Clinton both of which have
failed and this point wouldn't be
surprising if the media literally
awarded Neville Chamberlain you know a
Profile in Courage Award for
capitulating in his negotiations with
Adolf Hitler in Munich like we have been
saying the media cannot stomach a leader
that believes in peace through strength
and stands up to dictators all they want
they want a president to grovel and
cower and kiss Kim jong-un's rings
president Trump is proving he won't do
that and as a result he's winning he got
every condition he needed and a
discussion well about denuclearization
would be good for the world he's not
going to repeat the absolutely idiotic
and completely foolish mistakes of both
Clinton and Barack Obama now back in the
90s Bill Clinton came up with a
brilliant idea oh let's try and bribe
Kim jong-un's father Kim jong-il with
billions of dollars in energy subsidies
with the hopes that the North Koreans
would abandon a nuclear program
President Clinton actually took a
victory lap on national TV patting
himself on the back for brokering a
great deal for the American people he
was wrong look this is a good deal for
the United States North Korea will
freeze and then dismantle its nuclear
program
South Korea and our other allies will be
better protected the entire world will
be safer as we slow the spread of
nuclear weapons now Bill Clinton's
massive foreign policy blunder set the
stage for North Korea to actually
develop nuclear weapons billions wasted
and he is directly responsible for the
current situation we face today then of
course there's president appeasement
himself Barack Obama he tried to outdo
both Neville Chamberlain and Bill
Clinton with a timid feckless policy of
appeasement towards Iran and the radical
Muller's that are
calling for death to America the same
people promising a wipe America and
Israel off the map who burnt American
and Israeli flags in other words they
hate our guts
that didn't stop Obama from
orchestrating one of the worst deals
ever in the history of mankind
now the MPs are in chief he gave a ran a
hundred and fifty billion dollars while
still allowing them to spend their
centrifuges here's Obama surrendering to
the radical mullahs in case you're
interested today after two years of
negotiations the United States together
our international partners has achieved
something that decades of animosity has
not a comprehensive long-term deal with
Iran that will prevent it from obtaining
a nuclear weapon this deal demonstrates
that American diplomacy can bring about
real and meaningful change change that
makes our country and the world safer
and more secure this deal is also in
line with a tradition of American
leadership now unlike Neville
Chamberlain Bill Clinton and Barack
Obama President Trump is refusing to
give even an inch when it comes to
countering North Korean aggression watch
this
that's Korea best not make any more
threats to the United States they will
be met with fire fury and frankly power
the likes of which this world has never
seen before he does anything with
respect to Guam or anyplace else that's
an American territory or an American
ally he will truly regret it Rocketman
is on a suicide mission for himself and
for his regime yeah fury and fire for
rocket man and here's something the
abusively biased news media will never
tell you well since the 1990s Donald
Trump has been warning about the growing
threat posed by North Korea
take a look these people in three or
four years are going to be having
nuclear weapons they're gonna have those
weapons pointed all over the world and
specifically at the United States and
wouldn't you'd be better off solving
this really potentially unbelievable and
the biggest problem I mean we could talk
about the economy we could talk about
Social Security
the biggest problem this world has is
nuclear proliferation and we have a
country out there in North Korea which
is sort of wacko which is not not a
bunch of dummies and they are going out
and they are developing nuclear weapons
and they're not doing it because they're
having fun doing it they're doing it for
a reason and also tonight we have even
more proof exposing the media's
anti-trump agenda now according to the
new Media Research Center study 91% of
ABC NBC CBS is evening newscast coverage
about President Trump was negative in
January in February 91%
I've told you back a long time ago
journalism in America is dead what we
have now is a media that is only an
extension of the Democratic Party they
regurgitate the talking points their
singular purpose is to do what destroy
President Trump at all costs and the
truth be damned and all of these
statistics prove it now in the media's
efforts to delegitimize damage this
president they have all but blacked out
any positive news coming from the White
House just look at today's economic data
February's job numbers smashed
expectations 313 thousand new jobs were
created that's the best monthly gain in
over a year and a half and since
President Trump took office 263,000
manufacturing jobs have been created and
a record 155 million Americans are now
on the labor force and here's a
statistic the media will never tell you
about according to the Heritage
Foundation 64% a president Trump's
agenda is already complete that's faster
than President Ronald Reagan himself
which is astounding the media doesn't
care instead they're only hyper focused
on advancing their bizarre conspiracy
theory about Trump Russia collusion that
has no evidence of ever happening
there's no evidence has been no evidence
now while the media has been literally
taking you the American people down this
conspiratorial rabbit hole for over a
year here's what they've missed take a
look at the side of the screen those are
all of presidents Trump's
accomplishments have you heard the media
ever talk about any of these I doubt it
the media spent the past
and a half trashing the president at
every single turn they absolutely refuse
to give this administration credit for
anything it's 24 hours a day seven days
a week 365 days a year
non-stop constant attacks and a lot of
lies it's unlike anything we've ever
seen and sadly well it's only going to
get worse the more successful the
president is the heart of the media is
going to try to destroy him